we have the function f of x is equal to
x minus 1 squared minus 2 and they've
constrained the domain to x being less
than or equal to 1. so we have the left
half of a parabola right here and they
constrained it so that it's not a full u
parabola i'll let you think about why it
would make that would make finding the
inverse difficult but let's try to find
the inverse here and a good place to
start let's just set y being equal to f
of x we could say y is equal to f of x
or we could just write that y
is equal to x minus one squared minus
two
we know it's four
x is less than or equal to one but right
now we have y
solved for in terms of
x or we've solved for y to find the
inverse we're going to want to solve for
x in terms of y and we're going to
constrain y summarily and we can look at
the graph and we can say well in this in
this graph right here this is defined
for y being greater than or equal to
negative 2. so we can maybe put in
parenthesis
y being greater than or equal to
negative 2 because this is going to be
right now this is our range but when we
swap the x and y's this is going to be
our domain so let's just keep that in
parentheses right there
so let's solve for x so that's all you
have to do to find the inverse solve for
x and make sure you keep track of the
domains and the ranges so let's see if
we could add 2 to both sides of this
equation we get y plus 2 is equal to x
minus 1 squared right
minus 2 plus 2 so those cancel out and
then i'm just going to switch to the y
constraint because now it's not clear
what we're saw you know whether y is the
domain of the range or the x is the
domain of the range but we know by the
end of this problem y is going to be the
domain so let's just swap this here so 4
for y is greater than or equal to
negative 2 and we could also say in
parentheses x is less than 1. this is we
haven't solved explicitly for either one
so we'll keep both of them around right
now
now to solve for y or solve for x
you might be tempted to just take the
square root of both sides here and you
wouldn't be completely wrong but we have
to be very very very careful here this
is this might not be something that
you've ever seen before so this is an
interesting point here
we want to
we want the right side to just be
to just be x minus 1. that's our goal
here in taking the square root of both
sides we want to just have an x minus 1
over there
now is x minus 1 a positive or a
negative number
well we've constrained our x's to being
less than 1. so we're dealing only the
situation where x is less than or equal
to 1. so if x is less than or equal to 1
this is
negative
negative so we want to take the negative
square root let me just be very clear
here if i take negative 3 let me if i
take negative 3
and i were to square it that is equal to
9. now if we want to if we take the
square root of 9 if we take the square
root let's say we take the square root
of both sides of this equation and our
goal is to get back to negative 3.
if we take the positive square root if
we just take the principal root of both
sides of that we would get 3 is equal to
3 but that's not our goal we want to get
back to negative 3. so we want to take
the negative square root of that of r of
r squared so because this expression is
negative and we want to get back to this
expression we want to get back to this x
minus 1. we need to take the negative
square root of both sides you can always
every perfect square has a has a
positive or a negative route the print
root the principal root is a positive
root but here we want to take the
negative root because this expression
right here is going to be negative and
that's what we want to solve for
so let's take the negative root of both
sides so you get the negative square
root
of y plus 2 is equal to and i'll just
write this extra step here just so you
realize what we're doing is equal to the
negative square root
the negative square root of
x minus 1 squared
for
y is greater than or equal to negative 2
and x is less than or equal to 1. that's
why the whole reason we take the
negative square root there and then this
expression right here so let me just
write the left again
negative square root of y plus 2 is
equal to
the negative square root of x minus 1
squared is just going to be x minus 1 is
just going to be x minus 1. x minus 1
squared is some positive quantity the
negative route is root is the negative
number that you have to square to get it
to get x minus 1 squared so that just
becomes x minus 1. hopefully that
doesn't confuse you too much we just
want to get rid of this squared sign we
want make sure we want to get the
negative version we don't want the
positive version which would have been 1
minus x don't want to confuse you so
here we now just have to solve for x add
1 and let me write 4
y is greater than or equal to negative
2.
add 1 to both sides you get negative
square root of y plus 2 plus 1 is equal
to x
for y is greater than or equal to
negative 2 or if we want to rewrite it
we could say that
x is equal to the negative square root
of y plus 2
plus 1
for
y is greater than or equal to negative 2
if we want to write it in terms as an
inverse function of y we could say so we
could say f inverse of y is equal to
this or f
inverse of y is equal to the negative
square root of y plus 2 plus 1
for
y is greater than or equal to negative
2. and now if we wanted this in terms of
x if we just want to rename y's x we
just replace the y's with x's
so we could write
f inverse of x
and i'm just renaming the y here is
equal to the negative
square root of x plus two plus one
four i'm just renaming the y for x is
greater than or equal to negative two
and if we were to graph this let's see
if we started x is equal to negative two
this is zero so the point negative 2 1
is going to be on our graph so negative
2 1 is going to be on our graph let's
see if we go to if we go to negative 1
negative 1 this would become a negative
1 negative 1 0 is on our graph
negative 1 0 is on our graph and then
let's see if we were to do if we were to
put x is equal to 2 here
so x is equal to 2 is 4
4 square root principle root is 2 but it
becomes a negative 2 so it becomes 2
negative 1. so that's on our graph right
there so the graph is going to look
something like this of f inverse it's
going to look something like
something like that right there as you
can see it is a reflection of our
original f of x along the line y is
equal to x along the line
along the line
y is equal to x because we've
essentially just swapped the x and the y
this is about as hard of an inverse
problem that i expect you to see
especially in a precalculus class
because it really is tricky to realize
that you have to take the negative
square root here because the way our
domain was constrained this value right
here is going to be negative so to solve
for it you want to have the negative
square root